[Musique]
bonjour les amis bienvenue à manger
c'est beauté nous sommes dans le
vignoble bordelais nimbé de l'or du
soleil vieux bordelais qui est le
premier employeur de la Gironde qu'on va
visiter ensemble aujourd'hui un soleil
nous réchauffe peut-être trop pour les
raisins ce matin c'était différent
c'était les brumes de la Garonne
[Musique]
alors on est sur la Gironde et j'ai
rendez-vous avec Nathalie Delattre
sénatrice de Gironde vice-présidente du
Sénat qui va me faire découvrir son beau
département et les gens qui l'anime
bonjour madame la sénatrice bonjour
Vincent merci de m'accueillir bienvenue
à bord et
à bord
on est de plus en plus tourné vers la
Garonne oui tout à fait ça a été un des
enjeux de la renaissance de Bordeaux vu
par Alain Juppé et ce matin on est dans
une brume qui sent un petit peu la fumée
le charbon de bois quand même oui nous
avons des reprises de feu
malheureusement on a connu ça tout l'été
et on est encore sur une saison où nous
avons à faire face à ces problématiques
alors native de région parisienne tout
de suite parti en Aquitaine dans le
Périgord oui j'avais trois ans quand mes
parents ont décidé de déménager pour se
rapprocher du travail de mon père qui
était représentant dans ce secteur et ma
maman femme de ménage les études en
revanche direction Bordeaux oui des
études de droit qui m'ont amené en
Gironde et ensuite à m'installer dans
cette merveilleuse ville café du droit
pour rentrer dans la police et en fait
je suis effectivement rentrée en
politique j'étais assistante
parlementaire et ensuite j'ai eu
différentes missions dans des
collectivités territoriales locales pour
insister des politiques bon il y a
toujours une transmission verticale dans
ce monde de la politique donc
certainement des gens qui ont marqué
votre carrière et votre jeunesse alors
j'ai commencé en Dordogne avec Yves
Guéna et puis je suis arrivée ici j'ai
rencontré Jacques Chaban-Delmas mais
j'ai aussi rencontré le parti radical
valoisien à l'époque ensuite rencontrer
Jean-Louis Borloo qui m'ont mis le pied
à l'étrier pour me dire tu es assez
porté les valises des autres il faut
maintenant que tu joues un rôle de
premier point
et du coup Alain Juppé m'a attendu cette
main et m'a proposé de le rejoindre dans
son équipe en 2008 et vous vous avez été
mer adjointe et on va d'ailleurs là vers
votre zone de Bordeaux oui qui
s'appelait avant le quartier Bordeaux
Nord et qui a été rebaptisé le quartier
Bordeaux maritime justement en l'honneur
du fleuve et de cette renaissance et
alors on voit émerger deux piliers un
peu comme le pont de Londres mais de
façon plus moderne c'est le pont qui
porte le nom d'un de vos mentors oui le
pont Jacques Chaban-Delmas qui a un
tablier levant nous sommes presque la
dernière destination à accueillir des
choses très importante dans votre vie il
y a une chose aussi qui prend une place
préminante le vin d'ailleurs on m'a dit
que vous aviez un diplôme de
dégustatrice effectivement j'ai passé le
diplôme universitaire d'aptitude à la
dégustation
qui est décerné par la faculté de
Bordeaux et qui m'a permis de pouvoir
assembler nos vins à la propriété
j'espère qu'on va lever nos verres plus
d'une fois aujourd'hui au cours de ce
périple qui sauvent
vous avez toujours été une centriste le
portefeuille à droite le cœur à gauche
en fait je suis et de droite et de
gauche d'un côté aujourd'hui ce qui crée
la valeur ajoutée de la France ce sont
les entreprises mais tout ça peut être
très précaire et du jour au lendemain on
peut se retrouver dans des situations
difficiles et donc il faut savoir
mettre en place des amortisseurs sociaux
et en fait la politique c'est de trouver
le juste milieu entre les deux
entendre aujourd'hui et de penser que le
gaullisme social perdu
allez direction le Bassin d'Arcachon où
nous attend Olivier un ostréiculteur
très engagé puis Saint-Loubès ou
Emmanuel Favre la mère de la commune se
bat pour que sa cantine de l'école soit
la plus locavore possible et puis on
rencontrera Florian un jeune chef
reconverti dans le maréchal il y a tout
juste un an et Cédric éleveur du fameux
agneau de Pauillac qui a développé en
plus une activité fromagère et viticole
pour arriver à s'en sortir enfin
direction la cuisine de Thierry Renou
chef étoilé qui nous prépare une recette
100% girondine en route
[Musique]
donc en fait faut pas qu'à 8 sont
vraiment en face de la dune du Pilat on
peut pas faire plus près
Olivier
qui travaille sur cette parcelle on va
dire sur ce banc sur le long d'Arguin
l'ensemble des osseurs du bassin
d'Arcachon une parcelle et sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon on est à peu près 300
exploitants
300 entreprises on produit entre 10 et
15000 tonnes d'huîtres par an ce qui
amène une vraie valeur économique pour
le territoire mais c'est une forte
valeur
identitaire et patrimoniale quoi
sur le Bassin d'Arcachon et d'une des
plus vieilles hautes en France
[Musique]
donc ça ce sont des cages de profonde
dans cette culture c'est un métier très
difficile on est souvent courbé chaque
poche fait entre 10 et 15 kg là
l'avantage à ça c'est qu'en fait on ne
descend pas dans la mer ce sont les
cages qui viennent à bord du bateau à
l'aide de la grue ça a été inventé ici
ça ouais ouais tout à fait l'idée c'est
de faire aussi évoluer le métier parce
que ce métier on dit souvent les jeunes
et foutent rien ils veulent pas
travailler c'est faux les jeunes ils
veulent travailler
ça ce sont les jeunes pousses et c'est
ce qu'on vient rechercher ici on voit on
est parti d'une huître qui avait cette
taille et tout ça c'est de la nouvelle
pousse
c'est quoi chimiquement comme substance
la coquille c'est du calcaire comme le
marbre comme les falaises c'est du
calcaire nous on est sur un produit 100%
naturel on est bio par nature on ne peut
vous proposer que ce que la nature nous
offre quoi c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné s'il y a de bonnes conditions
alors évidemment il faut la mettre de
l'homme il faut qu'on les travaille bien
il empêche que c'est quand même la
nature qui fait 70% du travail quoi
attention c'est pas un vrai couteau à
huître non non
on envoie les huîtres elles ont
quasiment pondu donc ça c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour nous ce quand elles
sont très laiteuses qu'elles sont en
phase de pompe à travailler ses
compliqués elles sont très fragiles très
vulnérables et moi j'ai appris à les
ouvrir pour pouvoir les déguster parce
que un des freins effectivement à la
consommation des huîtres c'est ça
l'ouverture
mais par contre moi je leur dis préparer
l'apéro laissez-moi faire moi j'ouvre
les huîtres ça me saoule de voir les
huîtres mal ouvertes je supporte pas
avec des petits bouts de coquille dedans
etc
délicieusement un pur moment de bonheur
il y avait pas le moindre petit morceau
de coquille
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que c'est ici on se
trouve où là Olivier donc ça ce sont des
anciens parcs à 8 donc c'est plus de
1000 hectares sont à réhabiliter la
particularité du bassin d'Arcachon c'est
que c'est une écloserie naturelle de par
sa configuration les huîtres c'est une
nurserie c'est la plus grosse nurserie
de d'Europe pardon et là on commence à
en voir vous voyez les points noirs là
comme les poils d'une barre donc ces
huîtres elles sont vivantes elles vont
se développer on vient dans deux ans le
bloc il sera comme ça chaque huître va
faire 80 g il y en a 100 ça fait 8 kg et
là elles sont toutes en paquet d'un
point de vue économique on peut pas
récupérer ça le vrai problème c'est que
ces huîtres vont épuiser la ressource le
plancton le phytoplan c'est ça
mille tonnes d'huîtres que les
entreprises arcachonnaises produisent
par an et c'est 60000 tonnes d'huites
sauvages qui sont là vivantes et qui se
nourrissent tous les jours et qui ne
seront pas récoltés une huître ça se
vend un déjà il faut qu'elle soit là
elle est longue plus une asperge que
évidemment comme elle était serrée elle
a voulu pousser elle a poussé en
longueur donc ça c'est très peu vendable
nous producteur on essaie de faire une
huître ronde des creuse ici on vient de
nettoyer 34 hectares 34 hectares 34
hectares que sur cette pièce ça veut
dire qu'on vient avec des pelleteuses
des tracteurs pour faire simple c'est un
travail de terrassement à l'échelle du
bassin combien il y a d'hectares de
friches imaginons ou à ton calculer qui
devrait être nettoyé dans le meilleur
des cas globalement il y a environ 1000
hectares nous sommes fixés l'objectif de
réhabiliter 75% des friches ostréicoles
donc ça veut dire 750 hectares à
l'échelle des 10 ans
la mer est en train de remonter on va
pas pouvoir repartir là
pas là il est malheureusement sur le
bateau je vais chercher le bateau ça
sera plus judicieux n'oubliez pas
Olivier
on a connu des histoires de ce genre du
côté du Mont-Saint-Michel
[Musique]
ça me laisse sénatrice c'était
formidable cette balade sur le bord
d'Arguin et là direction la cantine où
ça alors nous allons à Saint-Loubès
c'est au nord de la métropole de
Bordeaux et nous allons rencontrer
Madame le Maire
ce que je vais vous montrer Vincent
c'est le travail qui est fait autour du
gaspillage alimentaire et l'introduction
des circuits courts dans nos cantines
je sais qu'ici vous n'êtes pas 100% bio
mais bio au maximum qui est un gage de
qualité et sanitaire à gustatif et aussi
le plus locavore possible quand c'est
possible tout à fait on essaye d'aller
au plus près de ce qui est la nouvelle
Aquitaine je me renseigne de l'achat des
fruits frais des légumes frais auprès de
mon fournisseur ou on a fait venir de la
pomme de terre de la commune bio un
fournisseur aussi de fruits de pommes
qui se trouve aussi sur Saint-Loubès
donc après on est content d'avoir des
fournisseurs plus humains on va dire que
des grandes centralisations d'achat on
essaye d'avoir de la bonne matière
première pour pouvoir bien travailler au
prix plus juste parce que c'est
important en fait la concurrence entre
les comptines Bordeaux et Mérignac qui
assurent des milliers et milliers de
repas en fait il pillent un peu les
ressources bio de l'ensemble de la
Gironde donc tout le défi c'est que les
533 autres communes puis celles aussi
accéder au bio et c'est ça le plus
difficile parce que le bio et puis il y
a aussi la différence le bio mais aussi
moi ce que je développe et vraiment où
là j'aimerais qu'on mette l'accent c'est
le kilomètre 0 parce que le bio qui
arrive des États-Unis n'a aucun sens
c'est vraiment qu'il arrive de local
oh ça y est le restaurant se remplit
j'ai l'impression salut les garçons
salut Vincent les impressionne quand
même on a lâché des petits pots mais ils
ont très faim je peux vous dire un peu
comme nous d'ailleurs
bonjour je peux m'asseoir là
bonjour
on a même pas commencé que vous avez
déjà fini mais vous êtes des rapides
c'est quoi le ticket moyen ici
j'imagine que ça couvre à peu près les
matières premières pour alors qui assure
le coup de personnel et près de
structure etc c'est la mairie alors
c'est clairement oui c'est déficitaire
une cuisine comme celle-ci elle est
déficitaire forcément donc c'est un
choix politique
d'investir de l'argent dans un repas de
qualité auprès des enfants en fait on
parle beaucoup aujourd'hui de
souveraineté alimentaire et on pense à
l'échelon national et parfois même
européen
nous sommes propriétaires de 10 hectares
avec un château et une maison de maître
donc il y aura 6 hectares dédiés au
maraîchage pour faire pousser les
légumes qui seront dans la tête des
enfants on aura une capacité à faire une
grosse partie de nos légumes
[Musique]
parce que j'avais des restes j'ai appris
qu'il y avait des poules
[Musique]
c'est la bonne purée de la cantine et
avec ça au moins
il y aura de bons œufs
vous voyez Nathalie c'est vrai que moi
je comprends la demande d'avoir une
offre vraiment locavore mais encore
faut-il la trouver et notamment chez les
producteurs de fruits et légumes pour ça
que je vous emmène voir Florian qui est
un jeune maraîcher qui a répondu à un
appel d'offre du conseil départemental
pour s'installer vraiment à proximité
des cantines scolaires qu'il servira
bientôt on l'espère il démarre juste
bonjour Florian vous allez bien Corbetta
donc vous vous êtes au début de votre
exploitation ça fait un an qu'on est
installé et ça brosse et bien lancé un
jeune comme vous qui veut démarrer dans
le métier a été obligé de passer par un
appel d'offres pour trouver de la terre
ici on Médoc oui parce que ici la terre
se fait rare il y a beaucoup de monde
surtout
beaucoup de vigne mais bon après c'est
ce qui fait la beauté cette région après
tout terrain ce travail là ici je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
pensaient pas avoir autant de légumes et
au final si on fait les bonnes choses et
qu'on apporte pas mal de matières
organiques il y a pas de souci ça pousse
ici vous exploitez sur quelle surface je
suis sur 7000 m² d'accord donc 07 ha
vous êtes tout seul ça veut dire que
pour exploiter il y a même pas quelqu'un
qui vous donne un coup de main non non
vous me diriez j'ai un potager
200 m² je dirais c'est déjà du boulot
mais là on est en train de parler de
7000 m² exploité depuis le semis le
repiquage désherbé arrosé vous occupez
le plan et le ramassage tout seul tout
seul c'est simple c'était ça
mais en fait les maraîchers qui sont
diversifiés à l'heure actuelle sur des
surfaces comme la mienne généralement
ils sont tout seul au début parce que
c'est les premières années on peut pas
se payer déjà on peut pas se payer et on
peut pas payer d'employés notre devise
c'est travailler plus pour gagner moins
ah bah ça pour vouloir mais c'est quoi
la compensation la compensation
le cadre de vie j'ai juste à faire
quelques pas et je suis dans mon champ
j'ai pas besoin de prendre de voiture
quoi que ce soit et ça ça vous
même si les fins de mois sont difficiles
ah oui complètement et peut-être aussi
le fait de dire que vous faites le bien
pour les autres aussi vous participez à
une à la bonne santé de la population
exactement et ça on le voit à la vente
directe les gens on a beaucoup de Roméo
enfin tout le temps en pratiquement
toutes les ventes on a des remerciements
et c'est ça qui motivé aussi les
commercialisations donc vous vendez
directement ici à la propriété vous
allez livrer des cantines je vends à
deux magasins il y a un magasin des
producteurs qui regroupe justement un
peu tous les producteurs de Gironde et
autres d'accord je sais pas si vous
connaissez cagette aussi je pense qu'il
faut plusieurs systèmes aussi
sans avoir qu'un système de
commercialisation parce que déjà on
pourra pas tout écouter c'est quasiment
impossible je regardais votre terre à
95% du sable du coup dans des années
sèches comme celle-ci l'eau est un vrai
problème non cette année j'ai pas
forcément plus arroser que ça après il y
a les variétés aussi un peu plus
résistantes donc faut jouer avec ça
aussi merci Florian mais de rien avec
plaisir bonne journée vous cassez pas
trop le dos dans les patates non non
vous inquiétez pas
[Musique]
visitons Cédric Perez qui est éleveur
viticulteur et nous allons rencontrer
aussi son président de la filière de
l'agneau de Pauillac ah il fait des
agneaux très bien et là c'est le
garde-manger vous avez vu toutefois
bonjour on peut entrer oui venez rentrer
merci Vincent
allez allez
l'IGP agneau de Pauillac elle existe
depuis quand l'agneau de Pauillac est
une marque qui a été déposée en 1988 il
faut qu'il soit né en Gironde 1 un
éleveur contrôlé sous le label agneau de
Poyac comme Cédric ok que il soit à la
battage qui soit contrôlée et certifié à
notre Pauillac avec un abattoir qui est
dans la région oui aujourd'hui nous
abattons à Bègles puisque nous avons
notre propre outil d'abattage local loco
local pour vous qui êtes éleveur quel a
été l'attrait de travailler l'agneau de
Pauillac plutôt que simplement de
l'agneau français ou l'agneau Europe et
nation mais la trait c'est surtout que
sur la Gironde on a ce label donc qui
dit qui dit
IGP dit un agneau rémunéré un peu plus
cher pour les éleveurs combien on est à
9 euros du kilo attention quand on dit 9
euros du kilo on parle de la carcasse
avec les os et tout ce qui ne change pas
donc n'estimez pas que vous allez
retrouver votre agneau de Pauillac à 9
euros chez votre vendeur non là on parle
pris des parts carcasses OK
et est-ce que ça c'est suffisant pour en
vivre
il faudrait un peu plus il faudrait un
peu plus mais déjà c'est déjà bien parce
que en Gironde cette filière là c'est
notre porte drapeau la faire évoluer la
faire avancer avoir des jeunes qui
puissent reprendre des exploitations ou
créer des exploitations comme moi je
l'ai fait et installer des jeunes ça
c'est un vrai problème quand on parle
justement de foncier oui effectivement
le partage du foncier d'une des clés de
l'installation de nos jeunes
agriculteurs ici en Gironde Cédric
d'ailleurs montre cette diversification
il a su allier élevage et viticulture
donc je pense que c'est l'avenir et on a
cette problématique d'incendie ici en
Gironde il faut qu'on regarde si on peut
regagner aussi sur cet espace forestier
planté mais sous les plantations pouvoir
aussi élever nos brebis les
exploitations agricoles en Médoc c'était
c'était un peu de lait un peu de
céréales un peu de vigne il y avait un
peu de tout la viticulture est arrivée
en force dans les années 70-75 et on a
tout planté en vignes et je pense qu'on
a fait une grosse erreur là où les
anciens ont voulu gagner de l'argent et
toutes les exploitations ont été
reconverties en monoculture comment ça
vous a coûté ici 160000 euros la
bergerie la bergerie avec les tapis
d'alimentation et tout le complet si je
comprends bien le prix d'une maison en
gros oui et ces banques agricoles qu'on
connaît bien est-ce qu'elles sont là
pour vous vous savez quand vous allez
voir le banquier c'est jamais simple moi
je me suis battu pendant trois ans pour
arriver à avoir un bâtiment comme ça et
avant ça pas été fait avant mais on
était j'avais fait au moins de recours
on était sous des tunnels en bordure
d'estuaire de la Gironde avec
avec une grosse catastrophe en 2010 avec
la Xantia où on a perdu des
brebis on a perdu du foyer on a perdu
tout un tas de choses mais vous
remboursez votre crédit aujourd'hui mais
il me reste on finit en 2028 de payer ce
bâtiment là et il me tarde que ce soit
fini ce que vous dites c'est que c'est
une affaire de personnes plus que
d'algorithmes il faut trouver le bon
interlocuteur bon on parle on parle on
déguste pas beaucoup hein
j'aimerais bien déguster la tomme de
brebis Cédric on y va
[Musique]
franchement bravo c'est bon elle est pas
trop salée pour moi c'est parfait c'est
assez rare quand même de faire les trois
à la fois la viande le fromage et le
Main ouais moi je dirais bien on est
bien en Médoc
on est bien en médocs
[Rires]
[Musique]
on était dans l'agneau de Pauillac très
belle région viticole on va voir des
viticultrices mais pas à côté d'ici un
an à l'autre bout du département dans le
Pays foyen
Nadège et Laurence impérial sont deux
sœurs qui ont racheté le domaine à leur
papa l'enjeu de la transmission est
aussi un enjeu compliqué ici
[Musique]
bonjour mesdames bonjour
Alors vous étiez en train de vendanger
un petit peu comme ça
à l'ancienne
faut dire qu'on sort d'une période pour
la viticulture et notamment dans la
région compliquée là depuis deux ans et
demi trois ans il y a tout eu c'est vrai
qu'on a accumulé les crises la covid
barrée restaurant fermé crise financière
puisqu'on a eu la taxe Trump et des
problématiques de marché aussi chez les
Chinois et puis et bien la crise
climatique avec en quelques mois le gel
la grêle le stress hydrique la canicule
est-ce que c'est l'angoisse la vendanges
cette année enfin est-ce que vous êtes
tendu là on a passé je pense notre
premier jour de donc on a ramassé les
blancs déjà il y a 10 jours et on a
commencé les rouges mardi
je pense que c'est une des pires
journées de vendanges que l'on ait faite
voilà c'est à dire que nous on est
hochet on attend il y a rien qui arrive
on a suivi un grand nombre d'hectares
lundi avec ce nombre d'hectares on
faisait trois cuves pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée on en a pas réussi à
remplir une à fond comme on les remplit
d'habitude
Grelet on savait à peu près combien ça
allait donner puisque on allait des
experts qui sont passés pour l'assurance
donc on savait à peu près par contre ce
qui s'est rajouté c'est ce stress
hydrique c'est à dire que même les
voisins qui étaient pas grelets nous
disaient non mais tu as fait 20 que toi
hectare dans ta parcelle brûlée mais
nous où on avait deux lavandes d'ange on
est à 35 normalement si on est à 55 60
on va dire à Bordeaux de rendement on a
à peu près 10 hectares sur la propriété
qu'on ne va pas en manger
le rendement n'est pas suffisant
mais sinon on aime ce qu'on fait
c'est du jus de raisin encore tout à
fait vous faites pas du jus de raisin
non c'est dommage parce qu'il est très
bon c'est peut-être un débouché auquel
il faut qu'on réfléchisse effectivement
donc vous voyez déjà la couleur la
différence en 48 heures on a un nez qui
est passé du jus de raisin à la cerise
noire voilà
écoutez je serais bien resté trois
semaines moi pour goûter le vin le 20
nouveau le vin à la sortie de sa
fermentation mais ça promet
[Musique]
écouter Nathalie on va retourner à
Arcachon ça me manque de plus ce matin
et puis je voudrais vous faire
rencontrer un chef comme ça
bonsoir Thierry bonsoir ça va bien alors
je vous ai amené votre site
on va faire travailler ma relation on va
déléguer aujourd'hui je vais essayer de
faire ce que je peux on va retire le
pied de cochon avec une farce fine de
volaille en dessous on a un petit toast
de pain de mie qui va apporter ce
croustillant j'essaye de réinventer
justement des choses qui existent depuis
très longtemps c'est qu'à Noël Sud
Bassin d'Arcachon on fait la crépinette
de porc avec les huîtres trouver ce
muscle et alors là
le petit claque de la charnière
et c'est pas mal ah oui voilà maintenant
on va prendre les huîtres qu'on vient
d'ouvrir et on va les enrouler de l'art
de Colonnata donc avec un gras
exceptionnel c'est vraiment le grand
lard italien
j'y crois pas au milieu ah bon
voilà et on referme en portefeuille en
quelque sorte voilà tout à fait
[Musique]
vous avez bien travaillé Nathalie bravo
il se passe un truc est-ce que ça encore
un sens le bio à un moment où le pouvoir
d'achat est tellement en baisse ou
l'inflation
flambe est-ce que ce surcoût les
Français sont prêts à l'accepter moi je
pense que c'est une tendance
que effectivement il faut peut-être
acheter moins mais de qualité moi mais
mieux la viande comme pour le vin tout à
fait et
arriver à trouver ce point d'équilibre
pour faire vivre nos agriculteurs donc
il faut que nos consommateurs retrouvent
les circuits courts retrouvent cette
envie d'aider nos agriculteurs et les
aider c'est payer quand même le juste
prix mais
effectivement il faut savoir acheter
convenablement et les portions
nécessaires il y a un sujet qui vous est
cher Nathalie c'est dans l'éducation
l'éducation à l'agriculture de nos
jeunes de ceux qui veulent acquérir du
de la terre pour être agriculteur même
si la finalité et le bio qui devrait
être juste l'agriculture normale il faut
passer par le conventionnel oui
complètement parce que nos agriculteurs
de demain nos jeunes agriculteurs vont
arriver des fois sur des exploitations
qui ne sont pas encore converties où on
court de conversion il faut qu'il sache
faire le conventionnel et en vivre déjà
avant la conversion avant la conversion
merci beaucoup Nathalie delat de m'avoir
reçu accompagné dans votre Gironde et
nous on se retrouve bientôt sur Public
Sénat avec des producteurs aussi
passionnants et des sénateurs et
sénatrices aussi passionnés que Nathalie
à bientôt
[Musique]